well the crowds are starting to gather
here at the duermo of Milan Cathedral
where the state funeral is taking place
many of them are political supporters
of his Forza Italia Flags that's his
political party flying in the background
now of course the people who've turned
out here have come to remember and
commemorate a man who they see as a
great Italian who did great things for
this country but you should also
remember that within Italy he was a very
polarizing and divisive figure now how
you see him depends of course on where
you stand in that political fault line
the people here think as I was saying
that he was a great man and a great
Italian he did everything well after his
controversies are part of him are part
of the person but also the good he did
is part of the person I I want that
Italian remember him also for the good
because his staff is taken out to what
he did good he was really a great person
very nice very friendly
he did all what he did he did with all
his strength and against
us against everything in the end it got
really
a good result in many things that he did
yeah I think we will split into Parts
like the one of writing the mother of
left so I think there will be two
different opinions about him
but for you he was a and your friends he
was yeah great man that's a great man
yeah but if you went and asked other
people who haven't come out to pay their
respects they will point out the
numerous court cases that he was
involved in and they will point out that
he was oftentimes a ridiculous figure
who used the office that he had to
enrich himself and inflate his own
status but I think whatever your
political persuasion is I think
everybody will agree that he had an
enormous amount of talent for winning
elections he was an extremely gifted
orator who managed to connect with
people in a way that other politicians
couldn't he was a norm breaking man
often railing against the political
Elites Point painting himself as the
Common Man with the common touch and
irony perhaps that in death at least he
has become a towering figure of the
establishment afforded a state funeral
and a national day of mourning